we have some other news come out today
this week so I'm so excited about this
one if they have dropped a teaser for
the final season this week the
Dragonstone map table of Westeros and
some miniature figures representing the
major remaining houses are covered in
eyes some one half with stark the wolf
and Targaryen dragons the five side with
the Lannisters obviously being the lion
until they meet in the middle
if reminds you of the 90s cartoon star
of the x-men this is version of that
that's right
some fence actually do believe there
that when they meet in the middle
because when ice and fire tried to fuse
together it's creating what they think
could be a new wall made out of dragon
glass but these people is going to be
foolish or even if it's just dragon guys
in general like they need that in order
to be able to fight the weapon anyway
guys how literally do you think we need
to take this tiny bit of T's I like the
fact that it varies yeah like are we
gonna pick this apart and be like look
this is how literal it is or is it just
because it's you know the battle between
ice and fire do you think that the exact
map positions and where we're seeing the
figures and representations on the map
is maybe a clue of what's to come in
this season yes it seems like we're
crazy
you're losing Winterfell that Winterfell
is gonna fire and that seems pretty
close it's like the first you have like
Castle black and last hearth and karhold
but Winterfell is a big capital yeah
it's it's in the name but what I like
somebody had pointed out to me but that
if you see right when they meet it looks
like we're right over the Trident if you
guys remember the Trident owns one of
the biggest battles in the history of
modern Westeros at least where I almost
said Robert Kardashian
they're fans you know what you talk it's
sort of an empire really what a dynasty
that is Robert Baratheon sounds way too
much like that the Baratheon family okay
so on the Baratheon
they killed Rhaegar Targaryen it led to
I mean everything that you've seen with
Daenerys is based on that moment so the
Trident is his famous place also
remember in the water there's like oh
yeah or there was the legend right
babies in his chess players place we
visited various times to be really cool
there now there's a second really
important battle there because that
battle also is the one that no one
thought that Robert would win they're
like well Rhaegar is gonna win and take
back breaker it's it's a critical area
it's like several generations of things
have happened there that's where like
Arya and Joffrey got in their little
duel right that would happen right in
that same location that's um I would
have been killed yeah and yeah and yeah
in that town that's right there the end
by the boy yeah
and then there was Robb Stark in his
battle in the start of the war the five
good no it was yeah start the world five
kings he was able to evade Tywin's
forces and like end up capturing Jaime
Lannister and that was nearby famous
well this spot where it's again just
moves right like the right person can
win a whole war based on what they do at
the Trident yeah so literally this I
don't think that the dragon turning into
ice is just because we already saw a
dragon turn into that I prop that's
probably we will wink it or not the fate
of a certain Targaryen probably that's
me saying that there's two two that I
know of there's no I mean I probably the
Targaryen family is not going to make it
out of this season probably I'm seeing
that happen no one's allowed to be
happening I don't know where everyone's
related know cuz you see the dragon
which you say was the house sigil for
avatar garand you see it iced over like
a Winterfell Winterfell Falls and you
see the dragon so I'm thinking that
the Targaryens don't make it out of this
one it would be interesting because then
they could have maybe a stark family
reigning over Brandon shot so hard if
bran a shot come on man
well little weirdo we're so excited he's
yeah let us know what you guys think
else is going on that we missed in that
Game of Thrones
teaser I do think that there is a lot of
relevance to where they put the lines of
a they put that level of effort into
everything they do not let us know
anything we miss